you know it's interesting is everyone
here tonight I mean you all Fabozzi who
know about me and Ryan I don't have me
you've never seen us live before well
well welcome to our cult
lock the doors podcast shun wait a
minute I'm gonna call I have news for
you Ryan you're leading the cult this is
how it always works no um right Ryan and
I are debt free we've been debt free but
here's the thing like we were in the
corporate world I made really good money
thank you I made really good money in
the corporate world but I spent even
better money and so there was a point at
the sort of apex where I made a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year but of
course I had the big suburban house with
more toilets than people I didn't
actually own the house I just you know I
paid the bank on this 30-year mortgage
that I had I had the closets full of
designer clothes I had luxury cars
plural I had more than one Lexus I don't
know what the plural for Lexus's pretty
sure it's LexA okay and and so I had all
I had accumulated all of these things
that make me look rich but I was broke
man and it got to a point where I wasn't
just broke I was broke in because I
realized like the person I wanted to
become the person who was contributing
to a community the person who was
helping other people the person who was
living a life that aligned with his
values I wasn't that person in fact I
was getting farther away from that
person because I was spending money I
didn't have on things I didn't need to
impress people I didn't even know and in
doing that I realized I needed to to
make a change and it meant simplifying
my life and make making some sacrifices
in my life it meant delivering pizzas
for a while to pay off some debt even
though I was in the corporate world it
meant doing some things that I was not
comfortable with doing so that I could
eventually live the life I wanted to
leave
and now that you know we've got the tour
and you all paid money to get in here
tonight and if I wasn't debt-free if I
didn't have that foundation that I
couldn't say this next thing is a
hundred percent of the profits from this
tour are going to build a grocery store
in West Dayton we're from yeah thank you
thank you
so we're from around the street Dayton
Ohio
it's the overdose capital of America and
the west side doesn't have a single
grocery store there's a million people
in the metro area a couple hundred
thousand people in the city the entire
west side of the city is a food desert
second hungry City for families with
children and ever since 2008 they have
not had a grocery store on the west side
and we're trying to help change that but
if I had massive amounts of debt I mean
the thing I would have to do right now
is well you all paid some money and so
I'm gonna go pay off that debt and that
would be completely acceptable but now
that I'm debt-free
I have some options that I can do with
that money
I love the word options I do I really do
because no one wants to be limited it we
all want options we want choices we want
to make some decisions about things for
ourselves we want decisions and options
for our food for the things that we
drink how about for your dreams we want
we need to have those options as well I
was in your camp I'm a former banker my
income would rise each year but guess
what
so with my stupidity no I'm serious you
all I would do it I would just I was
like all right you know what I'm gonna
get serious when I make more money and
I'd make money and I got more serious I
got so mad I got my my w-2 one year
right and I look at it I go this amount
of money came through my hands and I was
like where did it go I got mad or when I
got my car I was like I'm gonna go find
my money no hon see I was so irritated
right and I drove by the mall and I was
like well someone in there and there's a
sporting goods store and restaurants and
I realize I took my money and I made it
their money because I had a problem I
didn't have limits I didn't understand
my goals I'm a hard worker but at some
point you have to realize your hard work
alone won't get you there you need a
plan that actually will work and so it's
so important for us to have that
awareness
but then to make those adjustments you
know debt is a thief it steals it steals
from you now and it steals from your
later if you start to think about that
and so I want more people to have more
of their dreams that they're living I
don't want you to go work for a Visa or
Discover or American Express or any of
those other people because here was my
wake-up call if something happened to
one of my children Visa American Express
and all the rest of them none of them
would care enough about me to come to
help me
they take that's a one-sided
relationship so that's not a good thing
so I had that wake-up call and a
perspective change for myself so much so
I sacrifice the motorcycle
you